hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that i played a few moments
ago
uh against myself uh or rather against
my bot on chess.com
uh there you have it uh when the good
people of just.com approached me and
they asked whether
i wanted to to have a bot uh.com that
people can play against
i said sure but let's uh make my avatar
not only myself but also include meadows
he's also a pretty big uh
pretty big deal here so i will be
playing against
myself and meadow here and of course uh
the first thing i wanted to check
is whether or not um uh well my bot
would would be
interested in going for some evan's
gambit action
so uh without further ado let's check it
out as it is quite an interesting game i
was um i was actually amazed at myself
that
the the game was so interesting so let's
check it out i i of course
went for e4 as i usually do with the
white pieces
and my bot replied with e5 i played
knight f3
uh my bot played knight to c6 and i went
bishop to c4 this is the italian game
and of course i'm checking whether uh my
bot is interested uh
uh to go into some evan's gambit action
and uh
he is bishop to c5 was played and i
immediately went for b4 and yes the
evans gabit is indeed on the board here
and my bot captured here bishop captures
on b4 which is what you should always do
in this position
uh and here i chased it away with c3 uh
i'm not i'm not sure if any of you know
but i made a
a little tutorial on how to play the
evan's gambit not
a while ago so if you guys haven't seen
that do check it out i will put a link
to it
in the description below it will be the
first thing you will see so here i'm
chasing back the bishop we
mentioned there that the bishop to a5 is
possible bishop to c5 not so great
bishop to e7 is possible
and there's even the very interesting
defense of bishop to d6 but here my bot
goes for the
main line which is bishop to a5 i strike
in the center with the d4 we have e
captures on d4 and now while you wanna
usually castle here i
i prefer the queen to b3 move as it
offers some very very interesting play
and here my bot went queen to f6 i never
know whether whether you should go queen
to f6 or e7 here
i haven't really done all that much
research on this but i think both this
both is actually fine so queen to f6 and
i just castled here it's a bit too soon
to go for any action in the center of
the board and you still have to worry
about this so i just castle here
uh hoping that my bot goes uh for for
someone
more pong grabbing but uh that was not
the case here and uh
in that tutorial i made i often
mentioned the bishop to b6 is sort of a
key move
in every defense black has here because
you want to free up that a5 square for
the knights to
uh to challenge this queen and the
bishop on c4 but here now my bot
went after i castled for d6 and okay uh
it's uh not not the greatest maybe of
maneuvers because my bot allows me to
just
grab the pawn here and then i haven't
really uh sacrificed all that much
but instead of this uh instead of this
capture i went for bishop to a3
which is a very very sneaky maneuver but
it's always dangerous
okay if you play this online maybe in a
blitz or bullet game maybe it can work
but against a computer it really
shouldn't so here
my bot decided to capture on c3 as now
the pawn is defended both by the queen
and the bishop here and i can't uh can't
really recapture with the knight and
that's a problem because i just lose a
piece
so here i instead played e5 uh just
blocking the queen's defense to the pawn
and then i said okay i'm gonna capture
it next
uh we have d captures on e5 grabbing yet
another pawn and now i recapture here
knight captures and already
it can be very dangerous uh the the
knight can come
to d5 the knight can come to e for uh
harassing that queen
so here my bot decided to eliminate this
knight this bishop isn't really doing
all that much on a5 and it does seem to
be
uh the uh the absolute best move by the
engine so bishop captures on c3 was
played
i had to recapture which is uh not all
that great as i lose uh this pressure on
the f7 square but okay
uh and here bishop to e6 just uh
preparing
to trade off the the light square bishop
and here uh i
actually missed a good opportunity to go
for bishop to b5 but
i i didn't really see what was all that
impressive about it yes i'm threatening
to capture here
but bishop to d7 it can be playable and
then if i for example captures captures
then
i do get to win back my pawn but then
for example after queenside castles it
still looks like a very
uh very interesting game uh black is
still up material but
you know i can bring my rooks over to
the queen side and start some sort of an
attack
but i went for a different plan i went
to bishop captures on e6
and here uh my bot captured with f
captures on e6
you could also capture with the queen
for example queen captures and then i
can even go for this knight captures an
e5 a temporary peace sacrifice because
okay
if the queen captures then you just win
the queen with rook to e1
that's game over and if the knight
captures for example knight captures i
can still play rook to e1
and it's uh it's going to be a very very
interesting game uh
you have to do something about this for
example f6 f4
and then the game continues i still
prevent any king side uh play but uh
black is
more than uh welcome to castle queen
side and then it's gonna be
a very interesting game so here after
bishop captures an e6
the bot did not capture with the queen
rather with the pawn uh
and here i just brought my rook rook a
to d1
now uh what i wanted to do here was
prevent uh
the king from castling king side and
also i don't want him to be castling
queen side so here i'm very happy even
though i'm down material
i'm keeping the king in the center of
the board which is kind of in the spirit
of the evans gambit
and here we have e4 chasing away my
uh my knight here but also offering a
trade of queens and i
i definitely don't want to trade queens
i already uh
sorry the the interface seems to be
lagging a little bit uh
let me just refresh that uh so yeah uh
we
we left it off at e4 so after this
e4 move uh my uh bot
is preparing to capture the knight but
also offering the queen trade and i do
not want to trade queen since i'm
down i can't even see how many pawns i'm
down three pawns
so i of course played knight to d4 i
could also try
and go for a temporary piece sacrifice
with queen b3
but i decided to go for knight to d4 and
here
is the moment where the magic happens
now uh what do you play here
so obviously the the the king has to
figure out what to do whether
the king will go queen side whether the
king will stay in the center of the
board whether you
want to try and maybe play some like
king of seven and then castle
king's side i don't know but here black
is
actually better black has to play a move
that it's it's not easy to play this
move but
if black plays a rook to d8 then my
position becomes difficult because now
my knight is attacked three times
and i really don't have a good response
to this i would have to play bishop to
c5
and then black will be uh black is just
better black is enjoying his extra
material as i did sacrifice some pawns
for the attack
uh and uh no you cannot chase away the
bishop with b6 if you're wondering about
that because i can just capture that and
then the
the knight is under attack that's not a
problem and of course if knight captures
on d4
i can just capture back with the bishop
so that's
there's also that so uh b6 is not an
option but here
black doesn't even have to worry about
that black can just continue with knight
g to e7
continue development and enjoy his uh uh
upon's advantage however to my uh
to my amazement uh rook to d8 was not
played or rather rook did come to d8 but
here
black actually castled queen side which
seems even better
because now the king is a bit safer the
the king castle and there's still this
triple attack on the d4 pawn and here
on the d4 knight and here i thought okay
i messed up
i sacrificed some pawns didn't really
work out but uh you know i still
looked and uh there actually is a win
here
uh so feel free to pause the video and
try to find a winning idea here for me
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
trying to sacrifice your queen and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
knight captures and c6 this is what i
played and i was very happy with this
move when i found it the point is that
black rooks are not connected so if my
queen is accepted with queen captures on
c3
i just deliver checkmate with rook
capture 78 and this is checkmate so this
is not an option but it's not
easy to find a move that works here
because if you just
win the knight then just queen captures
on c6 and there's queen to a8
checkmate not much you can do here it
doesn't matter if you trade rooks
because then the other rook
again guards this square and you are
still delivering checkmate here
there's no defense here and if king to
b8 then this also runs into rook to b1
check and you are again getting
checkmated king c8 queen a8
check it's important to notice that the
bishop covers all of these squares so
after king d7 rook to d1
and the black king has no more squares
the bishop cuts off the king from here
queen covers the back rank and now black
would have to give up the queen and this
would end in checkmate
so after i play this knight captures on
c6 it doesn't appear
that black has a good move so black
finds one uh rook
captures on d1 just eliminating my rook
and here i should just capture back rook
captures on d1
and then the same thing applies but i
for some reason
i decided to capture the the knight uh
the pawn here on a7 with checkpoint
being that uh okay
uh if the king goes uh king goes to d8
then i'm gonna recapture with check but
if the king goes here which was played
in the game
then i continued with knight to c6 check
uh my idea was that uh well you can't
really
go to a8 because this is just checkmate
and if you accept uh
the knight only then if the knight is
accepted i'm gonna play queen to b3
check and then i can recapture and
continue my mating attack
so here king the c8 was played and now
only now i play
rook capture sunday one again offering
my queen
uh but the queen cannot be accepted for
the exact same reason
as uh if queen captures then rook to d8
is checkmate
uh a very nice uh position that shows
how important it is to always connect
your rooks because if you're behind on
development
such things can happen so here my bot
captured
on c6 but here it's just a game over
you can do queen captures on c6 followed
by queen to a8 i played queen to a5
it's it's kind of the same idea uh and
here is
whatever black plays that's just game
this is the threat of checkmate and if
if you try defending then we we run into
the checkmate that we've already seen
king the c8
queen to a8 check king d7 now the bishop
is nicely slicing all the way here and
rook to d1
check ends the game the queen has to be
uh
given away and the rook captures on d4
will be checkmate
so here uh instead of resigning uh which
is kind of a shame i i hope the the bot
would resign here but bot actually
played queen captures on f2
uh but you know bots bots are like that
they don't resign they just
you know play any move that prolongs the
game i capture the queen e3 check i
captured the pawn
and then king to b7 but now it's a
fourth mating three
doesn't really matter what you play i
played bishop to c5 now threatening
check and mate and it doesn't matter
what black plays knight to f6 was played
i played queen a7 check
uh king the c8 and now queen to a8
checkmate
so i was very very happy that i was able
to win this game it's the first game i
played against my bot
and um well quite quite a lovely one i
was able to
find this uh offer of a queen sacrifice
after this after this uh well not so not
so great idea
but it's a fun position because rook the
d8 good for black
uh rook the d8 with castling losing for
black i mean just terrible
so i was uh indeed very happy to find
this uh
so uh this is uh it's the the best
game i could have hoped for uh for the
first game against my bot and also for
the promotion of the evan's gambit the
greatest opening there
is and ever was uh so uh that's the guy
a game i hope you guys enjoyed it uh
do check it out the people at chess.com
asked me if i want to change anything if
i want to add anything
when you play against the bot the bot
also uh talks a little bit about how the
game starts also
uh let me just show you this is the uh
this is what
the the bot says after the game is over
uh let me just
find it oh yeah okay uh
there it is uh this is what the bot said
uh congratulations you are a real
master of the game okay i maybe wouldn't
say that
exactly i would maybe say you are a true
master of the game but but it works you
know maybe maybe something that
that can be edited later but i thought
if you guys want you can also
uh try challenging the bot and then if
you guys have any preferences to any
lines that i use in my videos or any uh
you know
fun stuff that i say you can also use uh
you know
suggestions in the comments of this
video and i will transfer them to the
good people at chess.com maybe maybe
they
will be able to implement them if they
have time
uh first link in the description below
will be an evidence gambit tutorial
as you can see i didn't uh play it uh
like perfectly uh the the bot was always
better
uh up until this point it's not much
it's it's plus one so
it's definitely playable if you decide
to play the evidence again but you have
to
be comfortable being down by by a
centipawn
uh you know by the engine's evaluation
but uh the bot uh did play in the spirit
of the evans gambit and inc
instead of going for a stubborn defense
allowed me to play this beautiful queen
sacrifice so that's that's really
awesome of the bot i i
really really enjoyed that uh so
um hard to say
uh a very very enjoyable game and um
i i must say i i really impressed myself
with
with how not with the quality of the
game but with how nice
uh the game turned out so you know it's
the result that matters
so yeah all the important links are in
the description below so check that out
as well
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank derek lee
uh tan lui hai uh josh and giorgio
santos uh silas berlin and griffin
bassman for your contribution to my
channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have fun uh crushing my
my my bot see you soon